こんにちははじめ社長ですいやー
暑いねー時でなぜなんですけども夏といえばやっぱり外でスポーツしたくなりますよね
だけで今日ですねちょっとサッカーに絡めたちょっと客をやろうと思ってるんですけど
も8分はリット
これが
沖から心臓止まるんじゃねーか外のドッキリ今回準備しておりますそれが出て
いただけると
者がもうちょっともうより今の良さそうですね
日本を代表するサッカーのもう有名選手と言ったらこの方でしょ
長友 sunday
[拍手]
ブーブー筋トレの動画ツイッターでちょいダサティロさんにお願いしたことありました
今日や移動かこれ
今日がちょっとでも練習してたら突然 a
長友選手がインターセットドア切りまあられないと思います
こんな豪華なキャストないですよじゃあインターセプトは結構得意なんでですよねそう
ねっはシャーシ大根多く冗談でしょはあああ
からサッカー場とかフットサル場だったら長友選手いそうじゃないですよ
はいじゃなくて絶対なそうな場所で撮ってなかったよねーっ
将棋だと思うんですよ三は僕その1近かったしないと思っなんと僕蔵からこう観て
いただいてエメさんがパスをしてきたタイミングでその1枚突破
んでそうですねアロよろしい
[音楽]
ブーブー re
続そこら辺ねー
んんだぞ none
me
ウズ
ん
rar
ええええええ
やってました w
[音楽]
うううう
uh
ben
配偶者
uh
[音楽]
はぁん
[拍手]
ん
[音楽]
行かないん
goo
ああああああ
[音楽]
それと思います遊 you do
f
[音楽]
ています
ん
分
うん
tar
car
わあああああああああ
ああああああああ
[拍手]
me
彼
うまってはそうなるわなっ
[音楽]
ple
ブーバーン女神なそんな感情いらんだっん
いや屋上でエンチャ政府が北20年以上サッカーっていますが始まりです勝っ本当に
てありがとうございました
ブラウン